[موسيقى]
في هذا المكان المخصص لجناحنا ، يمكننا
الدخول فعليًا إلى مكان خاص جدًا
وهو برج الرياح ،
هذه هي الغرفة التي تم
تشييدها فوق الأرشيفات السرية داخل
الفاتيكان ولا يمكن للزوار الوصول إليها
بشكل منتظم ،
لذلك  كيف قررنا تقديم
جولة افتراضية لأولئك
الذين يأتون إلى موقع المعرض ،
ما يمكننا رؤيته هنا هو في الواقع
الرحلة التي
تسمح للناس بفهم كيفية
انتشار معرفة علمية معينة
وزراعتها داخل المحكمة البابوية ،
وقد تم بناء هذا البرج بعد  الوقت الذي
تم فيه إنشاء التقويم الميلادي
بالفعل ويظهر
ثلاثة عناصر أولها أنه
يمكننا رؤيته على آلية
[موسيقى] السقف
التي
توضح اتجاه الأجنحة على
الجدران ، يمكننا
ملاحظة الكثير من اللوحات بشكل رئيسي من
الكتاب المقدس
الذي يقدم قوة
الطبيعة قوة الرياح قوة
الأمواج
ولكن في نفس الوقت على الأرض يمكننا أن
نرى خط الزوال
الذي
هو صليب
لرصد موقع الأرض
تجاه الشمس وعلى أحد الجدران الرئيسية أه
يوجد مضرب صغير
على وجه بلوتو صغير وفي
فمه يوجد
ثقب هو المصدر الوحيد للضوء
القادم  في هذه الغرفة
وتمكن علماء الفلك
من إجراء تجربة لإثبات أن
الحساب الفلكي
الحسابي الذي قاموا به
بالإشارة
إلى التقويم الغريغوري
وإلى عدد الأيام خلال
السنة الشمسية
كان صحيحًا ،
لذا فإن تلك الألوان النابضة بالحياة التي نراها هنا
للزوار
لا ترى على الإطلاق هذه الغرفة
تظل في الظل ،
ولكن هذا سبب لأنه إذا
رأيت
بسبب الظل يمكن أن يدخل ضوء الشمس
إلى هذه
الغرفة ويمكننا أن نلاحظ كيف أن
مصدر الضوء هذا يشير كل يوم إلى
عنصر آخر أو آخر  نقطة على
الأرض والضوء ينتقل من
النقطة الأولية ليصل إلى الذروة
في منتصف أغسطس ثم
يعود مرة أخرى
لذلك تم وضع علماء
الفلك  ز معًا في تلك الأيام وفي
النهاية يمكنهم إثبات أنه يمكنهم القول
أنه
بعد 365 يومًا سيصل ضوء الشمس إلى
النقطة الأولية ،
لذلك من خلال هذه التجربة يمكنهم
إثبات ذلك ويمكنهم أيضًا شرح
للزوار
كيف تم إجراء الحساب الرياضي الفلكي
و
لماذا يمكننا التأكد من
أن
السنة الشمسية بها
365 يومًا